السيده الرئيسه اعضاء المحكمه يشرفني ان
اكون
امامكم
و اتحدث باسم دوله اسرائيل مهمه اليوم هو
ان اتحدث عن المعاني
العامه
والمحافظه على الحقوق حقوق المدنيين
المطلوب بحمايته اود اولا ان
اعلق على سؤال
السياق الذي يمثل اطار العمل لهذه الدعوه
بطلب اجراءات
احترازيه جنوب
افريقيا تؤسس دعواها على السياق وذكرت هذه
الكلمه في مناسبات عديده وتقول بشكل خاص
انه من المهم ان نضع عمل الاباده في
السياق العام لسلوك اسرائيل تجاه
الفلسطينيين خلال ال 75
عاما
وتترك في لماذا التوقف عند 75 عاما لماذا
عدم الاشاره الى
1922 عندما وافقت على الطلب البراني في
1917 واعلان وعد
بفور ربما ايضا الى
دخول اليهود او القبائل
الاسرائيليه قبل 500
عام السياق المناسب والمباشر
ل معنى الاباده يعود الى السابع من اكتوبر
لكن مقاتلي حماس والجمعات
الاخرى دخلوا الى تجاوزوا حدودا معترف بها
دوليا وارتكبوا تلك
الفضاءات وهذه الاحداث هي التي تمثل
السياق الحقيقي لاتهامات
جنوب
افريقيا وهذا العمل
يعتبر اباده
حقيقيه كما قالت رئيس المفوضيه الاوروبيه
في الر من اكتوبر ليس هناك حدود للدماء
التي تريد ان تريق حماس ذهبت من بيت الى
بيت وحرقت الناس احياء وقطعت اعضاء اطفال
ورضع لماذا لانهم يهود لانهم يعيشون في
دوله اسرائيل و وهدف الواضح لحماس هو
القضاء على حياه اليهود في الاراض المقدسه
هؤلاء الارهابيون مدعومون
باصدقائهم في طهران لن يتوقف ابدا
وبالتالي فان اسرائيل لها الحق في الدفاع
عن نفسها طبقا للقانون الدوري
الانساني بطبيعه الحال هذه الفضاءات لا
تبرر التجاوز او انتهاك القوانين ردا على
ذلك لكنها
تبرر ممارسه الحق حق الدوله في الدفاع عن
نفسها كما هو موجود
في وثيقه الامم
المتحده لتضع حدا للهجمات
المتكرره ومنع نجاحها في تحقيق
اهدافها وك حماس ذكرت ذلك ب وتقول انها
اهداف
حقيقيه هذا السياق مهم جدا لانه يظهر
طبيعه الوضع
كما تبين بشكل خاص في السابع من اكتوبر
وانه نزاع
مسلح جماعه
ميليشيا مسلحه بشكل كبير
والعواقب التي ترتبت عن ذلك
الهجوم وهذا النزاع
المسلح بالرغم من انه مبرر لكنه لا
يبرر انتهاك القانون خاصه اذا كانت
المليشيا المذكوره تستهدف المدنيين
والمنشات
المدنيه ولا تهتم بالتسبب في اضرار للمدني
لمدنيه النزاع ايضا محكوم بالقانون
وبقواعد القانون الانساني الدولي طبقا
لمعاهده لهاي
ومعاهده 49 والقانون الانساني الدولي وهي
وضحه ويتم احترامها من قبل
اسرائيل مثل هذه
القواعد
والقوانين تقول ان الاضرار التي تلحق
بالمدنيين ماسوف
عليها ولكن الهدف العسكري من خلال انتهاك
القوانين وايضا انتهاك معاهده جنيف
وارتكاب جرائم حرب وجرائم ضد الانسانيه
لكن الفئه او التهمه الموجهه هي
الاباده جريمه الاباده في القانون الدولي
وتبقا
لمعاهده الاباده
الجماعيه
هي استخدام خبيث وهي تقف
وحدها
وقد تم وصفها بشكل صحيح بانها جريمه
[موسيقى]
الجرائم والمحكمه نفسها تشير في الثاني من
يونيو
1999 الى ان استخدام القوه والعنف لا يمثل
بذاته جريمه اباده
جماعيه وبشكل
خاص القذف او قصف
بالقنابل وبطريقه صيغه اخرى فان دعوى
الاباده اصبح يلجا اليه بشكل مبالغ فيه في
نزاعات هذا اذا طبيعه هذا هذه الجريمه سوف
تتلاشى اذا تم التساهل بها معها بهذه
الطريقه
في هذه
القضيه الماده
التاسعه من معاهده الاباده
الجماعيه تجعل اختصاص المحكمه
مشروط بطبيعه
وتاويل القضيه او
النزاع
وتاريخ تحديد وجود مثل هذه الجريمه هو
التاريخ الذي يتم فيه تقديم الطلب الى
المحكمه سواء كان
هناك جدل حول هذا
التاريخ فانه امر يتم تحديده من قمل
المحكمه وهي مساله محتوى واصل وليس
اجراء والمحكمه تاخذ بعين الاعتبار بشكل
خاص اي تصريحات او سائقه تم تبادلها بين
الطرفين النقطه الاساسيه هنا هي استخدام
كلمه تبادل بين
الطرفين بالنظر
لان الاتهام ليس يكفي ينبغي ان يكون هناك
تبادل حقيقي بين الطرفين وفيه عناصر وذلك
من خلال التواصل الثنائي
وان يكون هناك تبادل ومعامله بالمثل في
مثل في هذا التبادل مثلا المحكمه تقول ان
في حاله
ميانمار وجهات النظر المعبر
عنها ان وجود خلاف بين الطرفين ينبغي ان
يظهر ان دعوى
طرف تتم معارضتها بشكل خاص من قبل الطرف
الثاني وفي قضيه جزر المارشال هناك حاجه
الى ان الذي يقوم بالرد لا ينبغي ان يحرم
من فرصه رد
الفعل قبل
ان تصل المحكمه الى القضيه الى
المحكمه عندما توجه دوله
تهمه ينبغي ان تعطي الطرف الثاني فرصه
معقوله للرد قبل اللجوء الى
المحكمه وخاصه
في مساله بهذه الخطوره متمثله في الاتهام
بالعباده
الجماعيه وينبغي لهذه الدوله ان تقدم ادله
وبراهين معقوله وذات
مصداقيه هنا جنوب افريقيا تشير الى تصري
ريحات شفهيه
لمسؤولين ول تصريحات لوزاره الدفاع هذه
الردود لم تكن موجهه لا مباشره ولا بشكل
غير مباشر الى جنوب افريقيا ولا هناك ادله
على وجود معارضه حقيقيه من الطرف الثاني
الذي هو اسرائيل جنوب افريقيا لا تذكر اي
تبادل بين الطرفين
وهي الطريقه المالوفه
للتعبير عن وجود خلاف بين
طرفين وهذا يبين الطريقه التي تتعامل بها
جنوب افريقيا مع
الامر هي تعتقد ذلك لكنها لا لا تتصرف
بحيث يكون هناك تبادل
حقيقي البروفيسور دوارت يوضح ان جنوب
افريقيا
عبرت عن قلقها لمجلس الامن وفي تصريحات
رسميه و ايضا ارسلت ذلك الى
محكمه المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه المحكمه اشارت الى انه في هذه
التصريحات من قبل دوله
في تظاهرات متعدده الاطراف لا تمثل
تبادلا بين طرفي
القضيه وذلك لتحديد هل ان تلك
التصريحات مع اي ردود
فعل تظهر ان
الطرفين قد تبادل وجهات نظر
متعارضه وجنوب افريقيا اذا لم تقدم ادله
واضحه
والمحكمه تشير الى تصريحات خلال
مؤتمر ولم تدعوا الى رده فعل
واضحه ولم يكن هناك تعارض بين وجهات النظر
من
خلال غياب مثل هذه
التصريحات اذا بروفيسور دوارت لا يمكنه ان
يستنتج ان اسرائيل لابد ان
تكون على علم ب ما تقوم به جنوب افريقيا
من تعبير عن قلقها
وعن لكن ان الخلافه وجد بين الدولتين هذا
ليس خلافا هذا خلاف من جانب
واحد البروفيسور دوغار ربما يحاول
ان يقول
ان اعتبارات خاصه تنطبق على هذا
الخلاف طبقا للماده التاسعه دون ان يوضح
هذه
الشروط ونصل الان الى قصه غريبه حول تبادل
لرسائل
شفهيه بروفيسور دوغ يعتقد انها مساله
تبادل لا عواقب لها هذا فهم نبيل لمثل هذه
الامور لكنه يقول ذلك
لسبب سنراه
الان جنوب افريقيا
قدمت طلبا ضد اسرائيل في ال9 من ديسمبر
والطلب يقول انه في الحادي من ديسمبر
ارسلت جنوب افريقيا رساله شفهيه
الى اسرائيل ويقول ايضا ان اسرائيل لم ترد
بشكل المباشر على جنوب
افريقيا
وطلبها رسالتها الشفهيه هذا غير صحيح
اسرائيل ردت في نفس ذلك اليوم
و تلك الرساله تم توجيهها الى
وتلقت
ردا وفي اليوم التالي قالت انها تلقت
الرساله في ال 26
والعش المدير عام وزاره الخارجيه
الاسرائيليه اقترح على نظيره في جنوب
افريقيا ب ان يتم الاتفاق على تاريخ ل
موعد لمناقشه هذه المساله في ال 27 من
ديسمبر السفاره ارسلت ال جنب افريقيا
رساله
شفهيه
تقترح مثل هذا اللقاء او هذا الاجتماع في
اقرب موعد ممكن
ومحاوله
من السفاره لتقديم تلك الرساله تم رفضه
لوجود عطله في ذلك اليوم وفي ال من ديسمبر
لتقديم الطلب في الثاني من يناير
الطلب وال الطلب تم تقديمه الى المحكمه في
ال
من ديسمبر اذا
اسرائيل حاولت ان تفتح اجتماعا ولكن ذلك
تم
تجاهله بل
ان جنوب افريقيا بدات بتطبيق هذه هذه
الدعوه في اليوم التالي وهذا ليس
صحيحا ربما شعرت افريقيا بخطا ذلك ارسلت
رساله
شفهيه في الرابع من يناير كررت محتوى
الرساله
الاولى لكنها وضحت في اليوم التالي بان
رساله اسرائيل لم يتم تلقيها من قبل
الفريق المعني بالامر وتقول ان
هذه
القضيه او
الدعوه لا يمكن ان تحل بلقاءات
ثنائيه وردت اسرائيل في اليوم التالي
وعبرت عن
مفاجاتها وعرضت ان يكون هناك
مشاورات وعن
رغبتها ان
تقوم المناقشات بعد نهايه
هذه هذا الاستماع الى المواقف بشكل
شفهي جنوب افريقيا قررت بشكل
احادي ان الخلاف موجود بصرف النظر عن الرد
الو من جنوب من
اسرائيل ربما ان جنوب افريقيا لو انها
قبلت هذا
الرد وال
طرفان ربما قرر انه ليس هناك
خلاف وجنوب افريقيا عبرت عن قلقها فيما
يتعلق
بتهمه الاباده الجماعيه ربما لا ندري جنوب
افريقيا اذا
عجلت هذه
المحاكمه وينبغي الاشاره الى ان جنوب
افريقيا لم تعطي اسرائيل فرصه
حقيقيه
التحاور معها حول الامر قبل ان تقدم
دعواها الى
المحكمه ولنا ان نتساءل لماذا قررت جنوب
افريقيا انه ينبغي ان تظهر وجود خلاف طبقا
لمعاهده الاباده
الجماعيه ووجهت عددا من
الرسائل
ان اصدار المحكمه لتدابير
احترازيه ينبغي ان يقوم على اسس ولكن لا
يمكن القطع وبشكل قاطع بان
هنالك
وجاهه من الصعبه من مكان تحديد ف اذا كانت
هنالك وجاهه لهذه الدعوه ولهذا الطلب
اساسا فهذا يعتمد على الاثبات الكامل او
الغياب الكامل للاثبات
ويهدف الى ضمان ان المحكمه تعمل بشكل فاعل
وبشكل ناجع ولكن هذا يتطلب وجودا امورا
حقيقيه ومن موسيه فيما يتعلق ب تدابير
موضوع
الطلبه ان الاجراءات المرتبطه بالتدابير
الاحترازيه هي اليه معقده وتستدعي من
المحكمه ان تقرر وفقا لعدد من
الافتراضات التي يمكن او لا يمكن اثباتها
في مراحل لاحقه في اجراءات المحاكمه وهذا
امر صعب للغايه خصوصا فيما يتعلق
بموضوع جسيم يتعلق بمزاعم ارتكاب اعمال
اباده
جماعيه عفوا ربما
فقدت تسلسل الصفحه
نعم ان عبا الاثبات في مرحله نظر في موضوع
الدعوه هو مرتفع وهذا طبعا يتطلب اتهامات
ينبغي اثباتها من خلال ادله وواقعه قاطعه
لا لبس فيها ولا شك ولكن ليس هذا الحال او
لا ينطبق على الجانب الخاص
بمرحله التدابير الاحترازيه ولكن امر لا
يمكن تجاهله طلب من المحكمه ان تقوم
ب اصدار قرار بعدد من تدبير والتي تقوم
على افتراض ان هنالك اباده جماعيه
حدثت
ولكن يمكن لحكمه للمحكمه ان تربض هذا
الطلب اذا لم يكن هنالك ادله ويمكن
ان يمكن ان يكون هناك ثمن سياسي
ولطرح
ل اصدار تدابير
احترازيه من هذه الشاكله هذا يتطلب من
المحكمه ان تتعامل بشكل حذر وتفهم خصوصا
فيما يتعلق
بتقييم
المزاعم موضوع
الطلب